there is some good news I'm pleased to
announce from the White House
the pandemic
after what two and a half three years of
15 days to slow the spread the longest
15 days ever in recorded history
after all that time the pandemic
is over
Mr President first Detroit Auto Show in
three years yeah
is the pandemic over the pandemic is
over we still have a problem with covet
we're still doing a lot of work on it uh
it's but the pandemic is over if you
notice no one's wearing masks everybody
seems to be in pretty good shape and so
I think it's changing and I think this
is a perfect example of it
why is the pandemic over the pandemic is
over because Joe Biden says it is is the
pandemic over because anything has
changed about kovid in the last week or
two weeks or six months or a year
no nothing about covet has changed or
frankly even like two years no nothing
has substantially changed the reason the
pandemic is over is because Joe Biden
says so and the Way That We Rule now in
in the total state
is that if Joe Biden tomorrow comes out
and says we've got a pandemic again then
they would all believe it okay
he says look we're not wearing masks Joe
Biden never wore a mask he would
occasionally put one on for the cameras
but very rarely even when he issued his
own mask mandate he would violate it and
his family would violate it constantly
because it was never about kovid because
the pandemic such as it was never posed
anywhere near the threat that the libs
told us it did it was just a means of
control
and the pandemic was just part and
parcel of the broader Democrat power
grab and the irony of course is that the
more power they take the more they
ruthlessly suppress The Descent the more
they prattle on about our democracy but
we our current form of government the
shape of the regime is much much closer
to oligarchy than it is to a democracy
American government has never been a
democracy exactly the word democracy
does not appear in the Declaration or
the Constitution when it appears in The
Federalist Papers it has only invoked
negatively it's only criticized and and
invoked with disapproval okay we have a
regime that has parts of certainly a
some democratic representation
especially in the early days and then a
kind of aristocratic element to it for
the aristocratic interests and you see
that especially in the in the Senate and
a representation for the states and then
it's even got a kind of monarchical
aspect too in the strong executive power
in one man so it's a regime that has
different elements okay and over time
that has changed and they took away a
lot of the power of the Senate took away
a lot of the power of the states by
directly electing the Senators that
changes the nature of the regime took
away a lot of the power of the People by
expanding the federal bureaucracy
and now I think the system that we live
under is it was always kind of messy but
I think it's just much much closer to an
oligarchy and then the ruling class the
Democratic party which is the kind of
representative of the broader ruling
class they now tell us that if you even
consider voting for a republican you are
a threat to our democracy so if you've
got an ostensibly two-party system where
it is completely unacceptable and you're
being told this by the government it's
unacceptable to vote for the party out
of power then you don't really have a
two-party system you don't really have
anything even really resembling a
democracy you've got a kind of total
State and what I mean by the total state
is that the the regime ideology
infects everything
okay it's not it's not just that the the
government is over here pushing its own
views but you've still you can still do
what you want in your churches and your
schools and in your Civic associations
that's not it just use the case of LGBT
the government right now is actively
forcing the LGBT ideology on all of the
other ostensibly free institutions
such that if a school doesn't teach LGBT
ideology that school will be punished
that school will lose funding that's
school can be sued by the government if
employers don't Embrace LGBT they will
for sure be taken to court by the
government even churches now that's why
they're trying to pass this federal
marriage bill the federal marriage bill
is effectively would outlaw opposition
to the LGBT ideology for all non-profit
groups including churches that could
lose their tax exempt status and
basically would just destroy the church
and you see this in entertainment if a
movie doesn't toe the line on just to
use the example of LGBT that movie will
be heavily suppressed that that movie
will be companies will be anathema that
that's what I mean by the total State
it's not just some narrow area of public
policy or this you know within this
particular jurisdiction no it's the
whole thing okay and Joe Biden
saying that that is
that is the Democracy the democracy is
what whatever he and his cronies say
that it is you'll really see this with
the FBI so there's a report out now by
the Washington Times no one is talking
about this
the
the uh speaking of Nazis earlier uh Joe
Biden accused of pressuring the FBI to
fabricate extremist and white
supremacist cases this is amazing this
is another example of the nullstradamus
phenomenon I mentioned this on the show
a week or two ago I said the demand for
anti-black racism is much much higher
than the supply and so what what happens
is it's it's not just that we can all
get along and say oh this is great we
don't have all these racial problems in
the country that perhaps we once did or
that we would fear no no what happens is
people just fabricate the the racial
incidents and you see this on campuses
all around the country virtually anytime
there's been a racial hate incident an
anti-black racial hate incident it's
been fabricated by black students
themselves or by left-wing activists I I
ran through a Litany of these the other
day on the show there's a whole list of
them in my book speechless so now we're
seeing this proven proven correct at
least according to the Washington Times
Rank and file FBI agents or accusing the
Biden administration of exaggerating the
threat of white supremacists and
pressuring agents
to cook up domestic terrorist cases
involving racist extremists current and
former FBI agents told the Washington
times that the perceived white
supremacist threat is overblown by the
administration we all knew that here's
the part that's that's really shocking
they said top Bureau officials are
pressuring FBI agents to create domestic
terrorist cases and tag people as white
supremacists to meet internal metrics
you know at the end of the month you got
to watch you got to be a little bit more
careful when you drive why because we
know that police departments very often
have quotas to give out speeding tickets
and you'll notice this you're more
likely to get a speeding ticket at
certain times of the month than in other
times according to these FBI agents
speaking to the Washington Times it's
the same thing with the feds and and
instead of quotas for speeding tickets
it's quotas for neo-nazis and white
supremacists because they don't exist
the only time they exist is when David
Duke goes on CNN occasionally and they
say there it is here's the Ku Klux Klan
but they're not real okay it's imaginary
put that away with Bigfoot and the
Boogeyman
and this is what the agents say quote
the demand for white supremacy coming
from FBI headquarters vastly outstrips
the supply of white supremacy they must
be listening to this show
the agents obviously speaking on
condition of anonymity we have more
people assigned to investigate white
supremacists than we can actually find
of course and that's why you see so many
FBI hoaxes and so much entrapment and so
much egging on of people to to try to
commit some kind of even vaguely
white flavored crimes you saw it in
Michigan with the Gretchen Whitmer plot
you see you see it all around the
country
they're going to keep doing this
and why do I believe the report yes it's
Anonymous reporting I mean I trust the
Washington Times why do I believe it
because we know that the FBI has been so
politicized over the years we know we
just saw first of all we know the FBI
spied on the Trump campaign illegally we
know the FBI and the doj undermine the
Trump Administration and we know that
the FBI just kicked down the door at
Mar-A-Lago at the request of the
Attorney General mayor Garland at the
order of the Attorney General Merrick
Garland who's a Democrat hack political
appointee by Joe Biden
you can see them them talking about this
the guy the the FBI agents are
complaining about this
the FBI agents they're saying that
they're basically being used as
political tools no question about it
no question better though I really
strongly encourage you to go check out
the report at the Washington Times
because that is a real threat so you
think about all of this the country is
an absolute turmoil on every single
metric Biden is failing he's underwater
not just in terms of his performance but
in terms of popular approval he's
underwater on everything including covet
that's why he's got to say that the
pandemic is over now to try to get that
back in the news
so you think it'd be a slam dunk that we
could beat Joe Biden in 2024 right
but I don't know a lot of Republicans
are cautious about this because we say I
don't know they're probably just going
to rig it I don't know they're probably
going to change all the election rules
again to give themselves an advantage I
don't know they're probably going to do
this they're going to do that
is it in a free and fair election
there is not a single chance that Joe
Biden could win re-election there's no
way he would have to step down someone
else would have to come in
and yet now we don't know because we
don't really have faith in the electoral
system Democrats haven't had faith in
the electoral system for a while or at
the very least they've sought to
undermine it when they lose in 2000 2016
and 2018.
and then when they changed all the rules
last time the Republicans started to say
guys this doesn't seem very fair to me
so what happens now what's going to
happen in 2024 Joe Biden was just asked
on 60 Minutes are you going to run for
re-election and for the first time
he didn't give a clear answer
sir are you committed to running again
or are there certain conditions that
have to be right look if I were to say
to you I'm running again all of a sudden
the whole range of things come into play
that I have requirements I have to
change and move and do in terms of
elections in terms of election loss and
it's much too early to make that kind of
decision I'm a great respecter of fate
and so what I'm doing is I'm doing my
job I'm going to do that job and within
the time frame that makes sense after
this next election cycle here going into
next year making judgment on what to do
you say that it's much too early to make
that decision I take it the decision has
not been made in your own head look my
intentions I said to begin with is that
I would run again but it's just an
intention but is it a firm decision that
I've run again that I've been managed to
be seen this is the clearest evidence so
far that Joe Biden will not run because
he's using the election laws as an
excuse not to be clear here but I've
never heard a sitting president talk
like this so I look I don't know man I'm
a respecter of Fate we'll see what
happens I've got this soft intention but
we'll see and it's because it's just so
obvious the man can barely form an
English sentence at this point he's such
an abject failure the party doesn't want
him to run they want to put up a
different candidate and this is the
clearest evidence yet if you ask me to
bet today will Joe Biden run in 2024 I
would bet that he will not run in 2024
the only reason I would hedge that bet
is because there was no one to replace
him Kamala and Pete Buddha judge are
complete non-starters they're going
nowhere Gavin Newsom maybe has a shot
but he's even he is is not a very strong
candidate to replace Joe Biden and it
just looks like such weakness from the
Democrats for an incumbent to choose not
to run again look so incredibly weak
that they don't know what to do the the
Democrats have all of this power
but when it comes to actually presenting
their case to the American people they
fail and so now they're sputtering and
they're contradicting themselves they
don't know what to say I'm so glad you
like that clip now here's what I need
you to do you've got to ring that Bell
subscribe get the notifications on this
YouTube channel we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]